تتواصل العمليه العسكريه لجيش الاحتلال
هنا في مخيم طول كرم حيث لا تزال الاليات
العسكريه متواصله ومقت للمخيم لما لعدد
كبير في هذه اللحظات من الاليات العسكريه
هنا حيث نشاهد تحرك للاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه التي لا تزال متواصله هنا في
الشارع الرئيسي ل مخيم طول كرم وسط
مداهمات واسعه لعشرات المنازل تم خلالها
تدمير لعدد كبير من هذه المنازل واعتقال
مئات الفلسطينيين وتحويلهم الى مراكز
التحقيق المتواجده في انحاء متفرقه من
المدينه على العموم مخيم طول كرم حتى هذه
اللحظه يشهد حصارا واسعا ل ليوم ونصف
اليوم حتى هذه اللحظه حتى وهنا جيش
الاحتلال يمنع تحرك المواطنين او حتى
الحالات الانسانيه سواء بالخروج او الدخول
الى مخيم طول كرم خلال ساعات الليل و
ساعات الامس ايضا كان هناك مواجهات
واشتباكات مسلحه في انحاء متفرقه من
المدينه بالتزامن مع هذا الاقتحام هنا
هناك اقتحام لمخيم نور شمس وتدمير للبنى
التحتيه من قبل جيش الاحتلال حتى اللحظه
خمسه شهداء وعدد من الاصابات فاق ال 15
اصابه من بينها اصابات نتيجه للضرب
من امام مخيم طول كرم ليذ
جعار الجزيره